Hey honey.
phone is Ben.
>> That's me. Can you see me?
Oh, yeah. I do see you and I hear you.
How are you tonight?
>> I am good.
>> No, no, you look great.
>> Do I? Thank you.
>> You look great.
>> You got quafted.
>> I know. I got
>> I got scalp.
>> You got a cut there, man.
>> You know, this would have bothered me.
>> That's a little a little different than
I'm accustomed to.
>> When I was a kid, when I was not even a
kid, when I was a little younger, that
would have bothered me. But now, it
grows back so fast. just like, you know,
two months later.
>> Okay, hang on.
>> You having a moment?
>> You're like, is that me or is that you?
You're you're going in and out, buddy.
AJ, is that you?
>> Well, what? Can you tell That's me. Can
you Can you tell us about metabolic
syndrome before I uh
>> Can can I tell you about metabolic
syndrome?
>> Please tell us about metabolic syndrome.
>> Are you taking over here? You wrote the
book on metabolic syndrome literally not
figured.
>> I helped doc I help.
>> Oh, I see. Okay. Gotcha. Gotcha. Gotcha.
Okay. So, um most of the things that
happen in the body are metabolic.
Metabolic just means is it just means
about energy and most of the chemistry
in the body regard is around metabolism
the ability to process energy. Right?
So, where does energy come from? Two
main sources there. Well, not two main
sources, but there's macro and there's
micro or quantum nano really, you know,
quantum particles. You got food and you
got it broken down. Do you know food is
broken down to quantum particles? That's
what food happens. When you eat a food,
most of it is ejected and this tiny
portion is goes into your blood and it
becomes quantum particles
and it becomes quantum particles in the
most amazing chemistry that
I can't even tell you as a chemist you
know it wouldn't land because if you
understand chemistry it's just the and
why does that logo right over my head
there? That's pretty funny. It's like I
was cancelled and we
>> I didn't notice. I didn't notice.
>> Um, no, I'm teasing. So, um, anyway, the
food is turned into part into quantum
particles in what's called in the
outside part of the cell. They call it
the KB cycle. You may have heard the
Kreb cycle.
It's actually the outside part of a
mitochondria. And then the inside part
of a mitochondria, it goes to town in
what's called electron transport.
Okay. Okay.
>> Electron transport,
I'm not going to get into it because it
is the most in all of biochemistry by
far. It is the most incredibly
elaborate Rube Goldberg machine. You
know what a Rube Goldberg machine is?
>> We I do know what the Rube Goldberg
machine is.
>> Yes. A Rube Goldberg machine for the
listeners or the viewers is it's an old
cartoon. It was there was a cartoonist
named Rue Goldberg in the 1930s, I
believe. And he used to make these
cartoons of like um like a a ball
dropping in a cup and then the cup
turning on a screw and then the screw
leading to a hole and then the ball
drops down the hole and the knocks down
four dominoes and it kicks over some
switch and
>> fly
Tom and Jerry
>> used to use Rube Goldberg machines on
the show. I don't know if you remember.
>> Is that true?
I don't I don't remember that. I wasn't
ever a big Tom and Jerry guy, but is
that I that vaguely does sound familiar
now that you're bringing it up.
>> Yeah. Yeah. So, Rube Goldberg, so the
except the body does it at the quantum
scale where this turns to that and that
turns to this and this switches on that
and opens up a gate here and this
electron moves over this way and that
turns on this enzyme and then enzyme
activates this switch.
That's the body, but it's happening at
the tiniest of scales. Can you imagine
this? With an intelligence
that allows it to go left and right and
safety valves and bypass and you know
that's the body. That's the way the body
works. And the most important part, the
most important um aspect of all of this
rub all these rub nano quantum Rub
Goldberg machines is how the body
produces energy. That's the crux of the
body. It's energy. Energy. Energy.
Energy. The body is purely about energy.
Getting it, using it, dispersing it. All
energy.
That's where all anything is. And so the
energy processes the energy
in general the collective energy
processes are called metabolism.
That's the ter that's what metabolism
means. Now metabolism is broken down
into two aspects. There's two types of
metabolism. There's the kind of
metabolism that builds and there's the
kind of metabolism that breaks down.
Right? There two n two two nature's
forces primal forces build up break down
anabolism catabolism right you have you
heard nabolism most people have heard of
anabolic steroids so you can relate
because it's anabolism makes build
muscle catabolism is breakdown they're
both important
out with the old in with the new you
always want new tissue you always want
new stuff the body's constantly doing
something called remodeling we're out
with the old in with the new out with
the old in with the new out with the old
in that's a fundamental process
And so metabolism is a balance of in
with the new, out with the old, out with
the old, in with the new. It's the
energy behind all of it. Both both of it
takes energy, but some energy causes
buildup, some energy causes breakdown.
It's all energy. Catabolism releases
energy.
Anabolism stores energy
with me. Catabolism
catabolic. Catabis has to be tightly
controlled, tightly regulated. Because
of this, anabolism
only happens when everything's right.
When all the systems are are geared to
go, we have tricked the body.
I don't know if we did intentionally. We
might as well have done it intentionally
because it was so con so directed, so
coherent
into thinking it's supposed to be
building. It's supposed to be anabolic.
We are hyperanabolic
in a not in a correct way. Anabolism has
to be done carefully with just the right
amount of resources and raw materials.
And you don't want anabolism just
building. We have tricked the body into
thinking it's supposed to be building,
but it's not building. And metabolic
disease
is an energy disease. It's a disease of
too much energy.
The body is being and specifically cells
are being bombarded, flooded with
energy. They're frying out. They can't
handle the energy. This is what
mitochondrial disease is. This is what
aging is. This is what metabolic issues
are. We have too much energy. That's why
fasting is so powerful. Fasting stops
the energy. It gives the body a chance
to catch up.
We have created a food supply
that has over the last 100 years
whatever 120 years or so it's probably
the late 1800s has been specifically
scientifically
you know uh targeted on creating
molecules that will keep you eating
energy. They call them hyper palatable.
The body loves energy containing foods
but usually energy containing foods in
nature they're not everywhere. And when
they are, they have B vitamins and
chromium and venadium, magnesium, and
fiber. And it's a complete package.
We've isolated all that hyper pal
palatable goodness and stuck it into
foods. And then on top of that, we've
created synthetically, we found out
little, we've gotten even more
fine-tuned with little molecules. Bottom
line is we're flooding our body with
energy. Think of what most people eat,
you know, and including me in this. I'm
not judging anybody because I'm
including me in this. You know, you need
a thousand calories a day. need, I don't
know, tw,000 to,200 calories a day if
you're an average person. You know, most
some people even less. We eat 2 to 3,000
calories a day. Sometimes more, some
4,000 calories. You know, we're getting
a calorie is a unit of heat. It's a unit
of its energy. You know, if you want
what happens to your Do you ever leave
your iPhone on your car seat, you know,
in the summertime? What happens to it?
>> It gets hot
>> after that. shuts down.
>> Shuts down. That's exactly right. No
machine, no high performing machine, of
course, the body is the highest
performing machine there is, right? No
high performing machine wants to run
hot,
right? That's why you have coolants. You
have fans, your computer, your Ferrari,
you know, wherever there's going
wherever you're running hot, you're
going to have a fan because no high-tech
machine wants to be hot. It burns it
out. It's very, you have to be very
careful. The body is the finest tuned
machine of all. So the less heat you put
in the body in the form of energy and
calories, the longer you live.
Conversely, the more the shorter you'll
live and the sicker you'll be. And
that's metabolic disease. And every
single one, everyone, it's a triangle of
disease except it what they're missing
is it starts off with digestion and and
the digestive system. And there's a link
between the intestine and bile and the
liver and the blood sugar system. So all
of that it kind of I call it two points.
It's really one point. It's really one
thing except the food is the macro
and the quantum is the micro or quant
you know smaller than micro nano or
phento or whatever pico.
>> Okay Ben I got
>> did I explain metabolic disease? You you
explain part one.
>> Okay. What's part two?
>> Part two is syndrome aspect.
>> Oh,
>> what does that mean? Oh, AJ, I love
that.
>> You are one smart cookie. It's a
syndrome. Yes.
>> So,
>> I call, you know what I call the
syndrome?
>> I know you know, but
>> I call the syndrome MBFA.
>> That's right.
>> That's what I call the syndrome. It's a
syndrome. Benz, Ferrari, and Audi.
>> What? No.
>> Benz, Ferrari, and Audi.
>> No. My body is falling apart disease.
>> Is that what you call it?
>> That's what I call the syndrome. A
syndrome.
>> Okay. You know I'm messing with you,
right?
>> Okay. I didn't know, but now I know.
>> You didn't know? Come on, man.
>> I don't know. I should have known. I
should have known.
>> Okay. Pharmacist Ben. Okay. I just want
to talk to you about the commonly
accepted
view of metabolic syndrome as per the
Mayo Clinic
and they're talking about identifying
you as having an apple shape and they
mention
uh
risk factors
>> being
precursors
to having metabolic syndrome as opposed
to the other way around. So they're
talking about
>> precursors. Say that again. I I don't
understand this. Precursors being one.
>> The Mayo Clinic is saying that if you
are obese or have diabetes or certain
other diseases like liver disease,
polycystic ovary, ov ovary syndrome and
sleep apnea. If you have these things,
it's increases the risk of you having
metabolic syndrome as opposed to
>> Uhhuh. Okay, got it. I got it. You know,
it's a chicken and egg thing. Who knows?
Maybe the metabolic syndrome started
before Well,
>> you can't This is what they're saying.
Hang on, hang on, hang on. They're
saying the structure is something that's
observed before the chemistry.
>> No,
>> is what they're saying.
>> They're saying they're saying that ha
being obese, having diabetes
and these other diseases increase
>> metabolic syndrome
>> increase the risk of chance of having
metabolic syndrome.
>> Yes. Yes. Yes. Because metabolic
syndrome is diabetes essentially. It
starts off as diabetes,
but it's a syndrome.
Well, diabetes is just a brand name for
for dis messed up blood sugar,
>> right?
>> You gota we got to start thinking about
diabetes from what it really is, not the
word. It's messed up chemistry, messed
up energy chemistry. Diabetes is messed
up energy chemistry. Period. Okay, sit
with that.
>> Diabetes is a metabolic disturbance. The
syndrome is all the stuff that happens
from the metabolic disturbance. The
syndrome is the high blood pressure.
It's the fatty liver. It's the dementia.
It's the cardiovascular disease. That's
the syndrome part. The dislycemia is the
metabolic part. Metabolic syndrome.
Are you with me? And it's also insulin
resistance. It's not just it's it's
insulin resistance. It's really the
insulin resistance that's the problem
because that that's the that's the
proximal that's the the the jumping off
point. But the dislycemia, the messed up
blood sugar comes from your blood sugar
going up and down and up and down, up
and down or staying up chronically
staying up.
Do you understand insulin resistance?
The whole how that whole thing happens.
>> Yes.
>> Okay. So eventually insulin resistance
will be the um and this is really
important for everybody listening who
wants to really understand this.
Insulin resistance
is the result of chronically high blood
sugar. Right.
The chronically high blood sugar is very
damaging. Sugar is costic. It's hot from
a metabolic from a chemistry standpoint.
It's hot. We're talking about heat. This
is super hot. Very, very. So, it burns
things. It burns collagen, especially
connective tissue. So, it's very
damaging to heart, to the to skin, to
bone. It's just damaging stuff. But even
worse
than that, that's bad. Even worse than
that is the insulin.
That's the worst. Let me tell I'll tell
you why in a second.
But understand that the insulin, the
high insulin is the result of the high
blood sugar, the sugar. So sugar problem
leads to insulin. High insulin,
chronically high insulin. Bigger
problem. You got problem plus bigger
problem. Not you got both.
Follow me.
>> I do follow you.
>> Okay. So you got an insulin problem and
you got a um I'm sorry. You got a sugar
problem, you got an insulin problem. So
why is insulin worse?
Sugar,
that's just a little molecule that burns
things. Okay, insulin throws the entire
system off. Entire head to toe, every
freaking nano
nanometer of circulatory system.
Everything is thrown off by insulin.
Everything. Insulin is a prime driver of
chemistry. prime maybe the most maybe
the most purely growth inducing
substance in the body is insulin. It
feeds cell. It tells the body it signals
to the body life is good. There's lots
of energy. We got lots to do, lots going
on. That's what so it drives the growth
process. But the problem is is we're not
growing. We're not foraging. We're not
hunting. We're not, you know, getting
well-rounded nutrition. We're not going
keto by starving a little bit every now
and again. We're not eating fresh woolly
mammoth off the fire, you know? So, we
we don't have any we don't have any raw
materials and we're just telling the
body, grow, grow, grow. It throws
everything off. It throws off the
androgens, the male hormones. It throws
off the estrogens, the female hormones.
It throws off all the building hormones,
all the steroids, all the stress
hormones. It throws everything off. It
disrupts the entire system. Insulin
does. The entire system, the body is
just like so exquisitely designed with
everything just just nano architected
spec the specifications, the tolerances
are like on the quantum scale. You know
what I'm saying? They're just so
pristine. And now you're just flooding
the body with this hormone that
historically was rare, relatively rare
because we didn't have a lot of food.
And now you're flooding the body with it
without the the the co-actors and the
assisting elements. It's a recipe for
disaster from a biochemical standpoint
that is manifesting in front of our eyes
clinically. It's a and that's the
triangle of disease.
>> Okay? You know, I added the adrenal
thyroid because and I probably shouldn't
have as we the more we talked about it,
but it sounded so cool the triangle part
and the thyroid and hypothyroidism is
really the jumping off point. So, I
wanted to include hypothyroidism, but
the thyroid is related to the adrenal
glands, which is related to the blood
sugar system, which is related to food.
That's how I came up to try it.
Far, I just want to read off some of
what you and I in the past or you and
Becca in the past have talked about as
uh different problems that occur as a
result in my opinion as a result of
metabolic.
>> Okay. Can I just say something before
you get going that
>> just discuss dispia but go ahead
>> discuss
I gave we gave the bad news the good
news is it's easy to change
it's easy
that's the good news you follow what I'm
saying
>> there's bad news is the mechanism and
what it leads to everything but the good
news is we can do this by changing the
way we supplement By changing the way we
eat, by changing the way we live,
anything you can do to keep the blood
sugar low, the insulin stable and low,
everything's stable and low really, the
longer you live. And every once in a
while, s uh sessation, stopping the
input of that energy is a a one of the
greatest gifts you can give to the body.
The body the body cleans itself out when
there's nothing in it. Like a
self-cleaning dishwasher. If you want to
clean your dishwasher, right, what do
you do? You run it without food, without
dishes. If you want to clean the body
out autophagy, that's what they call it.
Autophagy, cleaning it out. If you want
to clean out the body autophagiously,
fast. That's why fasting is so
important.
>> Okay. Uh I just want to I just want to
read off why
>> uh that we needed we needed to talk
about metabolic syndrome today as
the fundamental problem in America. This
is these are my opinions.
>> It is it is
>> the fundamental problem
uh in America in my opinion is metabolic
syndrome. And
>> is somebody writing this? Is somebody
writing this or you reading it?
>> And you're Is this
>> I'm reading I'm reading notes from you
and I and you and Becca's conversations.
>> I see. All of them altogether compiled
>> comp a compositive about 50
conversations
>> all about metabolic syndrome.
>> Uh
at least 30. Well, yes. You you touch on
the topic every show.
>> I have to. You cannot. So yes,
>> you cannot. It is everything. I call,
you know what I call metabolic syndrome?
>> Everything syndrome.
>> Well, I I want the folks to understand.
>> Don't call it metabolic syndrome. Call
it everything syndrome.
>> Everything syndrome.
>> The only system everything syndrome. The
only the only thing that go wrong in the
body that doesn't involve metabolic
syndrome is what?
>> What's the only thing in the body that
can go wrong? And even a case could be
made for for this for at least part of
this being metabolic syndrome is
digestive issues.
>> Digestive issues are are food issues
until the food becomes metabolized. Once
the food becomes metabolized then it's
part of metabolic syndrome.
>> I was thinking hypoxia might be one.
>> But like if you eat a food if you eat
the wrong food you have an ulcer or
something or you have h pylori. But you
know what even then on some level it's
going to be metabolic. it it's very
difficult to come up with something that
is not an aspect of metabolic syndrome.
That's why I call it everything
syndrome.
>> Okay. So
uh and yes in the notes you do mention
everything syndrome. You talk about
dislycemia and the toxin of sugar. You
talk about hyperinsul insulinia the
hidden culprit. uh insulin resistance,
growth hormones, and uh
>> you've been a busy boy there, AJ. You've
been a busy you've been busy. You've
been busy drives the development of skin
tags, cysts, fibroids, boils.
>> Dude, that's that's a volume. Hey, AJ,
we got to talk, buddy.
>> Downream.
>> Talk. We're gonna talk.
>> Uh belly fat, blood sugar issues, high
blood pressure. Uh it's also a root
cause of high cholesterol, diabet
diabetic
dysipidemia,
>> dysipidemia,
>> dysipidemia, fatty liver disease,
>> everything.
>> What do you want to do? Put us to sleep
reading. You know, you know what you
remind me of? When I was in pharmacy
school, we had to watch a movie about a
new drug. Did I tell you the story? A
new drug that came out.
>> Tell us about that drug.
>> And it's Oh, revolutionize
cardiovascular health. No more
hospitalizations, no more blah blah blah
blah blah. And they make you watch it.
They make you go tour the drug companies
too. They they freak they drive that
into you that propaganda. And so the
movie was about it was about a new drug
called inderal that we call propranol
now. It's a beta blocker. It was the
first beta blocker. Beta blockers po
they they block the beta nerve to the
heart. They slow it down. And that so it
was a very exotic mechanism for slowing
the heart down. Doctors love to slow the
heart down. cardiologist. That's their
main strategy is to slow the heart down.
And so, and and I can see the logic, but
it just seems crazy to me that you
poison the heart. They poison it.
Anyway, the movie was an hour long. The
lady read
the uh how great the drug was was for 15
minutes and the lady who read the side
effects was talking for 45 minutes just
like that. Just like what you read.
Well, and the reason I wanted to
highlight is because I wanted people to
understand that you or I wanted to
illustrate verbally that it is the root
of everything
>> everything
>> name these diseases. So when people say
how do I get rid of this because I get
the phone calls pharmacist bed
>> how do I get rid of this? Here's the
problem. Here's the problem and this is
this is a pro a very interesting dilemma
that we have and it's based on systems
theory.
So what do I mean by that? The body for
many years for hundreds of years since
probably the 1500s 1400s maybe even
before was looked at as being composed
of individual units.
And to this day when we work on the
body, we work on in the heart, the
lungs, the spleen, the intestine. You
have a you're sick female illness, you
go to an OB/GYN. A skin problem, you go
to dermatologist. Brain problem, you go
to neurologist. Prostate problem, you go
to urologist. A muscle problem, a
myiologist, a cardiologist. This that
specialties. We look at every part of
the body as special. It's not. It's a
system. And yes, there are individual
parts, but they're interacting in a
system.
Why is this important? Because in a
system, one of the one of the uh tenants
or pillars of systems theory, which is
all where all this is derived from I how
systems work is that all systems have
control points, bottlenecks,
areas that are like master areas that
can where you can control the rest of
the system. You follow what I'm saying?
This is the nature of systems to have
these bottlenecks. The system called the
human body has two major bottlenecks,
two major control points and they both
involve guess what? Energy because
that's the razone data of the body. It's
about energy. The body is just about
energy purely and simply like everything
is not just the body by the way but the
body has somehow figured out how to
it's too every time I think about blows
just blows my head open how the body
figured out how to work with energy in
this way but whatever so the two control
points not surprisingly in an energy
system are going to be energy control
points one where energy comes in to the
body at large and two where energy comes
into the cell or specifically the
mitochondria in the cell. Those are the
two places. Boom. Boom. They're the
first two points on the triangle of
disease. Why? That's why you have the
triangle of disease because these
represent control points. So, I brought
this up to say
that that's good and that's bad.
It's good because it's super powerful.
You know, leverage is powerful. When you
have one point that can do all that,
that's power. That's the greatest
invention. They sometimes say, "What's
the greatest invention ever, you know,
in the world?" And this man, people say
the wheel. No, the lever. The lever to
me is the greatest invention. It allows
you to get a little bit of work and get
a lot of benefit. And so, you're looking
for leverage points, places where you
can get a lot of bang for your buck. And
that's the two places where energy comes
into the body and into the cell,
specifically into the mitochondria of
the cell. And that's why the triangle of
disease and the two points are the the
everything.
They're the two control points that
allow you to have access to everything
in the body. And it's good because
they're simple. Stop the way you eat.
Change the way you eat. I mean, it's not
like you've been cursed, right? You just
change the way you eat. And I The
problem is though, that's the good news.
It's simple. You know what the bad news
is?
>> That it's so simple.
that it's so simple. Nobody believes it.
It's so simple.
Nobody believes because nobody
understands the nature of systems.
If you look at if you look at the body
as little pieces, the heart and the
spleen and the lungs to have a control
point doesn't make any sense. It sounds
silly. It sounds like uh you know like
air like panacea airy fairy. That's what
they want you to think because they're
not talking in systems. Because if you
understand systems, you understand makes
perfect sense to have control points
that you're looking for to control
everything.
And by the way, this is all engineering.
This is not biology. This is not
clinical. This is not doctoring. This is
not clinical chemistry. This is biology.
I'm sorry. This is um uh uh electronics,
physics.
>> Bio electricity is really the the best
thing you can call bio. Yes.
>> Pharmacist Ben.
>> Yes. Two things I'm gonna say before we
go on to try and tackle Andy's question.
>> Yes.
>> Uh I was was watching my favorite thing,
YouTube and Facebook.
>> I like YouTube. I've been liking
YouTube.
>> There was this guy talking about
in an electron microscope.
He's looking at the body and he's
finding
transistors
and all of these compon biological
transistors. You're talking about
>> biological trans.
I know it's true.
>> Shaped like
>> transistors use to make a radio.
>> 100%
a thousand% except it's quantum
>> quantum.
Quantum
>> quantum size transistors exactly
capacitors
>> 100%
>> dude we're energy devices
>> okay but how do we get capacitors in the
bloodstream like
>> the blood's a capacitor the membranes
are there's capacitors everywhere it's
all capacitance the body it's not
capacitors it's capacitance
you know what I'm saying so tell people
what a capacitor is a capacitor has an
ability to control electrical energy to
to to derive uh control the movement of
electrical energy to derive energy. It
holds it and traps it and releases it at
certain points. The entire body is one
big capacitor made up of an infinite
amount of sub capacitors that are
smaller than the rest. Exactly. And but
here's the thing that is to me by the
way I do this in skincare. I use this I
this is how I use my I make my skincare
products using these understandings. But
it's also why
nutrition is so powerful.
How does a vitamin work?
How does a amino acid work? How does a
an EFA work? An essential fatty acid
work. And how do plant- derived minerals
work?
They're frequency modulators.
They change the frequencies. So that the
and the frequency is just without
getting into too much technicality a
frequency is just a type energy like
right channel 2 channel 3 channel 4
those are all frequencies right KOA or
KBCco or you know all the different
radio station different frequencies
so there's all these frequency things
happening radio wave except they're not
radio it's different frequencies it's
much higher frequency than radio
frequency and frequency by the way
is so Cool. You know what frequency is?
Well, how would you say frequency is to
just in a non-physics way?
>> Wave.
>> No, that's physics already.
>> No, that's already physics, you know,
but in a way that you can actually see
or think about
frequency. If I take my light right on,
off and I do it every second. On, off,
on, off.
>> What's the frequency?
>> Not quite. Not quite. What's the
frequency? If I turn my light on once a
second, on, off, once a second, what
would its frequency be?
>> One.
>> Oh,
>> one time. One cycle.
>> Right. And that's your wave. One cycle.
If I turn my light on and off two times,
what's the frequency?
>> Two.
If I turn my light on three times per
second, what's the frequency?
>> Okay, let's say three.
>> Okay,
>> the body runs at trillions,
hundreds of trillions of times per
second.
Electrons vibrate at the rate of not
one, two, hundreds of trillions,
quadrillions maybe times per second,
depending on where on the spectrum it
is, but in biology, hundreds of
trillions.
How can something go on and off hundreds
of trillions of times? How is that
conceivable?
Can you conceive of something going on
and off once, twice, three times, 500
trillion?
That's the kind of game we're playing
here. That's the scale that we're
talking about here.
>> Okay.
>> Right. And the point is the point is
that system is easily disturbed.
>> It's very when things are moving at 100
trillion times per second, you could
throw them off. Imagine a fan. You stick
something in a fan. A fan's spinning
around how many times per second?
Whatever it is, thousand, 10,000, I
don't even know. 40,000 times a second.
However it is, I What do you think a fan
spins at? I don't know. 5,000 times per
second. I something crazy. Probably not
that much. 100 times a second.
>> No. No way. No. No way.
>> No way. I don't even know. Whatever it
is, that's whatever it is. If you stick
>> 50 times a second.
>> Okay. So, I can Okay, good. So, you put
your finger in there or put a piece of
paper in there, you'll throw it off,
right? That's how easily disturbed
something is when it's vibrating that
fast. That's why we die so easily. If I
shoot a bullet in somebody, what am I
really doing? I'm putting a tiny little
hole in them, but we die because all
that energy is like tightly compressed.
It's like boom, right? And so in any
case, the bottom line is is that the
control the way we can control all of
these systems is by the kind of energies
we put in or don't put into the body and
the support molecules that modulate the
frequency.
So you have macronutrients,
protein, fats, carbohydrates. They
supply the energy, the massive energy,
the big bonds of energy. The microeny
is the nutrients or the micronutrients
are the are working to modify.
They're like the spices that modify the
pure energy.
And that's why they both have to have
them together. You can't have one
without the other. Having micronutrients
without macronutrients, there's nothing
for the micronutrients to do. Having
macronutrients without micronutrients,
that's a disaster.
You know, I guess the first one's a
disaster, too, because you'll die of
starvation. But the second one is a
long-term disaster.
>> Okay, for Mrs. Ben, my second thing that
I saw online was that
uh we as humans are being cheated
because we don't wear leather shoes
anymore. And we're not getting the
energy from the ground. We're not
grounding.
>> It's 100%. Do you know about that? How
energy comes through the center of the
earth through your feet?
>> Well, I want you to talk about it.
>> It's called grounding. It's totally
legit. It's why people like to walk
barefoot, especially in the dirt or in
the sand.
>> In grass.
>> In the grass. Absolutely. You know what
that's all about? This is back to what
you were talking about here. Do you know
what the other name for these electrons
that are coming through the earth is?
>> What?
>> Negative ions.
>> Negative ions. Yes,
>> they're negative ions, right?
>> Mhm.
>> Negative ions are the I can't say it,
but they're that they're the bomb.
Negative ions are electrons. We live on
electrons.
>> I want to say that again. We live on
>> Hugging the tree.
>> Food. Food is electrons. The only reason
food is important is because of
electrons. And by the way, where do the
electrons come from? We'll talk talk
about that in a second. So, yes, hugging
a tree. Hugging a tree. Nature.
>> Um, not so much a dog. It has to be some
kind of nature some something that's
that's that's not expending its
electronic energy.
>> That's that's producing more electronic
energy than it's using. A dog's using
more electronic energy. A tree is not
really using as much electronic energy.
electrons, negative ions, whatever you
want to call them, as a dog is or a move
an ambulatory creature. So, they tend to
be in nature, trees, plants,
and all of it's coming from
>> the sun,
>> photons.
>> The sun is your daddy.
Do you remember? Do you remember
>> the son your daddy?
>> I'll tell you. I'll tell you.
>> No, just just the sun is your daddy. the
son is your dad,
>> right? And so you do you remember Pedro
Martinez, right? Oh, bring
>> he goes he goes he goes like one day he
made the mistake he go the Jankee is
there my daddy you know he goes he says
because they were kicking they every
time he went there they would beat him
right he go and he was a great pitcher
he was a awesome pitcher but the Yankees
had his number and he go the Yankees
they're my daddy and then every time he
came to pitch in Yankee Stadium they
would all go who's your daddy
>> is that great I cracked up who's your
daddy.
>> Absolutely.
>> So, the son is your daddy.
>> The son is the father of them all, man.
It all comes from the sun.
>> Okay. Wait, wait. Uh, I'm gonna attack
Andy. Yes, of course. I do understand
that the pyramid complexes are nothing
but big
>> solar solar, I don't know, solar
something or another, temples, all that.
Oh, yeah. If we can, if we love the sun
and the stars, imagine what native
people, they didn't have TV. They That's
all they're thinking about. That's all I
was seeing. What the heck is going on
out there, right?
>> Okay. Okay. Our friend Miss Philly is
asking, "With metabolic syndrome, what
would be the reason for someone having
problems gaining weight? Is that a
metabolic syndrome issue?"
>> Yes, absolutely. Absolutely. That
happens. That's that's the other side.
There's two ways it can show up. It can
show up as being really really thin
or it can show up as being really really
fat or in between of course but that's
another form of metabolic syndrome. The
thin version of metabolic syndrome.
Absolutely. And there's a lot of
dislycemic issues.
Disgues
uh mess up blood sugar issues that
affect the female reproductive system
for this reason. It has to do with male
hormones.
Insulin acts like male hormones,
right? Remember I said how insulin
regulates everything. One of its most
powerful interactions is with the
steroid hormone system, especially male
and female hormones. So, it will make
there is a form of um metabolic syndrome
that affects fertility and and menstrual
cycles. That's the female hormone
system. And there's a well that's both
hormone systems actually. And then
there's a form of um uh insulin
resistance uh hormonal issues where
you'll get muscular and lean and that
happens too. And what how one occurs and
the other doesn't occur. I'm not sure I
can answer that. There's probably, you
know, because the system is so complex.
There's probably reasons for one or the
other. I don't know exactly,
>> but the fix is the same whether you're
>> the same. Absolutely.
>> Big metabolic syndrome or small
metabolic syndrome.
>> Is the same. Yes. Fasting is is the
might be a start.
>> Fasting is an amazing start.
>> Even if you're too skinny.
>> Even if you're too skinny. When you
fast,
you're not going to lose unless you
don't have any body fat. You're not
going to lose muscle before you lose
fat. And what you're trying to
it's not, you know, people have a
confusion about gaining weight and
losing weight because we think weight is
weight. It's not. It's lean muscle mass
and body fat, right? That's the two
types of weight. That's the two major
types of weight. You don't want to mess
with your lean body mass. You you want
to your um your uh body fat. That's you
need some body fat for sure. You don't
want to be too too lean, but when you
fast, that's not going to really affect
your lean body mass.
>> Okay. Uh before I because Andy, we're
making you wait because you're you're a
smart guy, you know. We love Andy. We
love Bruce. We love Mr. T7, you know,
all all of our folks who are on with us
during the day and night, but we're
going to go our friend NC Golden.
I was told I have metabolic syndrome and
it's hard to lose weight. Also insulin
resistant. How can it be reversed?
>> You know, healthy blood and sugar pack,
reduce caloric intake. I I think maybe
I'm not dismissing the question, but we
talk about all the time, but it's good
to go over it.
Less calories is probably the first most
important thing, especially calories
from fast burning sugars.
Uh more protein, more fiber, more
micronutrients, correct other
inflammatory conditions, leaky gut,
drink more water, exercise.
Um,
additional nutrients from the healthy
blood sugar pack would include ultimate
selenium, ultimate niacin, MSM,
um,
probably a whole slew, magnesium,
osteomag,
um, zinc, zinc FX, the transition metals
are really important for, um, for blood
sugar. zinc um zinc and chromium and
venadium and um selenium. Those are
really important for the blood sugar
system. Just general blood sugar, all
the things we talk about blood sugar.
>> Now, the weight's not going to the
weight's not going to depending on where
they're at, how thrown off their
metabolic syndrome is, you know, you're
going to get more or less benefits
depending on where it is. you're
probably going to want to if it's really
severe, you're going to probably want to
throw in a lot of exercise or, you know,
not extreme, but just regular exercise.
Um maybe maybe uh breathing techniques
activate the parasympathetic nervous
system. Sugar is one of the big problems
with sugar and insulin for that matter
is they're inflammatory.
Actually, I should check about insulin.
I I'm thinking high insulin would be
inflammatory, but certainly sugar is
inflammatory. And so once the
inflammation system, the inflammatory
system has been activated, what do you
think happens? The inflammatory system
is like having an airbag go off inside
your biochemistry.
Systemic inflammation. Can you imagine
what an airbag going off of like a net?
There'd be a smaller airbag of course,
but a tiny airbag going off in there
would be that's what inflammation is.
Function
start eating breakfast at A.M. Even
though I usually
I wouldn't go by what your functional
medicine told you guy told you ever. Go
by how you feel. Go by how you feel,
what you feel like doing. He she he
says, "I only eat one meal a day and I
don't lose." That's because you have an
insulin problem. Insulin will keep you
from losing weight. High insulin will
keep you from losing weight. And there's
a lot of people like that. It could also
be at this point, I don't know where you
are in your health or uh I don't know if
you're a male or female, but it could be
Hashimoto. It could be thyroid disease.
Remember this is a triangle and once
you're at the third point
um everything slows down. The third the
thing about the triangle is it spins. So
the third point goes back around the
first point and second point and third
point it keeps spinning downward.
>> So if you're at the point where your
hypothyroid um you're going to have to
want to really take you have to do some
extra measures there to take care of the
thyroid.
>> Could a thyroid issue keep you from
gaining weight?
Yeah. If it's Graves disease? Yeah. Mhm.
>> Yeah. There's two ways thyroids can go.
Hypothyroid is a bummer. Hyperyroid is
an emergency.
>> Hypothyroid is just you feel tired and
sluggish. Every nothing works. You know,
hyperthyroid
that is a miserable miserable condition.
>> Can you imagine like you're revved up
all the time, sweating all the time,
your eyes pop out of your head, you it's
a curse.
>> But it's easy. Yeah, it's so bad they'll
actually take people's they'll take the
th they'll take it out or they'll
radiate it or they'll give you pills
that kill it.
>> I I remember when I was um in uh in
daycare, so I must have been like seven,
eight years old. There was this younger
kid whose eyes were popped out for like
>> poor kid for like
>> I know
>> for like two weeks and then they they
did something to him and his eyes were
normal again.
>> They probably did something his thyroid
I would guess. I I don't know. But
that's one of the things. Can you
imagine? Profuse sweating, anxiety,
jitteriness.
Oh my god. It's a curse. It is a real
curse.
>> Okay. Yeah. Uh, okay. I don't know whose
question this is, Becca. But while we
answer this question, Becca, can you get
me a phone number for where people can
call to buy the book Metabolic Syndrome?
Uh 15 years ago I was diagnosed with
gestational borderline diabetes. A
>> back to normal after birth of son gained
120 pounds. A1D still normal but insulin
resistance was tested as being high at
14.
>> Well the problem is not the A1C. A1C is
a sugar problem, not an insulin problem.
So whether or not it's normal, I don't
know what that means because usually it
seems like you might have a sugar
problem. But really, this all these
things are about insulin, not sugar.
Once you have a baby, that really throws
off your hormones. Again, that's because
or throws off your insulin. That's
because all your hormones are are
interacting with each other. They're all
connected to each other. You follow what
I'm saying?
>> That you know what the butterfly effect
is?
>> One one butterfly wing in America makes
it rain in Japan.
>> Yeah.
>> A tornado in Japan. I mean,
>> yeah. Something along those lines.
Exactly. Exactly.
Exactly. You do you ever see the movie
The Butterfly Effect? Like they make one
little change in the one little change
in the person's life and they go from
being this beautiful, you know, sarity
girl to some methhead or crackhead or
something. And it's just one little
change, one tiny little tweak. You know,
they were judging methheads.
>> What's that?
>> Not that we're judging
>> I'm not judging me heads. Do you ever
see faces of meth?
>> No.
>> You should Google faces of meth. I don't
I just could walk out to the court.
>> Yeah. Oh, yeah. Okay. Gotcha. Gotcha.
>> No. Faces of vest shows you before and
afters.
>> Oh, before and after.
>> Yeah.
>> Okay.
>> You haven't seen the after. You're in
the after.
>> Yeah. I'm seeing the after. I can
imagine.
>> Did you see the movie um Jacob's Ladder?
>> No.
>> You should see it. You got to see it.
The old one, not the new.
>> Such a reader. You see a lot of movies.
>> No, I I don't. Yeah, I do. I like
movies. I do. I like movies a lot, but
but no, I don't. I just have some
favorites. Um I have like a list of
movies that just I like movies that like
meaningful movies. So anyway, um Jacob's
Ladders had it's about new there's I
don't want to tell you it's about a lot
of it is about New York being a hell
realm
like the city and and I grew up there,
you know, and I was just there and I can
see why they did that. There you go.
metabolic syndrome are not genetic
diseases. Absolutely 100% correct.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Probably
um uh pretty accurate. Okay. Now, uh for
those who don't have grass or clean dirt
to walk on, would leather sole shoes be
sufficient or copper infused?
>> No. I mean copper maybe. Nothing like
those earth electrons.
Earth electrons. Do you know what the
biggest most concentrated source of
electrons
on Earth is?
>> Wait, don't say it.
>> I'll give you a clue.
>> The ocean.
>> Yeah, good day. Damn. That's one of the
reasons. That's one of, you know, why
would that be though? Why would it have
so why would there be so many electrons
in the ocean, do you think?
>> There's a couple reasons, I think.
>> Yeah.
>> Number one, the sun is beating down on
>> dude. AJ,
that's why you're the smartest man in
longevity, AJ.
>> Smartest man in longity.
>> There are people who are going.
>> Yes, sir. Yes, sir. The sun is
constantly being And what is on the sun
or what is on the ocean that traps the
sun
that the the most powerful most powerful
energy sources on the planet? What are
they
that trap the sun?
Plankton. No, plant
>> algaes. Algae. Algaes. That's what makes
algaee's the most powerful food on the
planet. The biggest animals on the
planet, what do they eat?
>> Algae.
>> Yeah.
>> How does a whale get that big eating
freaking plankton and algae,
you know? How how does that work?
Exactly. How does a plankton turn into
this beast?
>> Can you imagine how big a whale is? You
can't imagine how big a whale is.
>> Yeah.
>> No way.
>> Elephants, they're big, right?
>> There's probably like 20 elephants that
could sit on a whale's back or
something,
>> you know? I I don't know how big. It's
crazy. So, anyway,
>> Adrien Gold would would want to debate
you on this.
>> Who would who
>> Adrien Adrien Gold?
>> Is she listening?
>> She's not listening. I don't
>> What would she debate me about? Well,
she she she thinks the you know she she
loves pollen. She loves how pollen's
pretty no pollen you can make a you can
make a case for pollen being very
nutritionally dense. Absolutely. But
they're not electrically active like
freaking algae.
>> Mhm.
>> So yeah, there's nutrition in a lot of
things. Eggs, you know, there's a lot of
things that are highly dense with
nutrients and pollen are just that. But
they're not electrically active like
algae. I was sitting on the freaking
ocean,
minerals on the bottom,
photons on the top, algae in the middle.
What do you think's happening to those
algaes?
>> Holy moly. That's a freaking battery.
>> They're just supercharged.
>> Storage all that energy storage. Yeah.
Yeah. And that's why algae has protein,
fats, carbohydrates, vitamins, minerals,
phytonutrients, amino acids, everything.
Algae is the ultimate food. And by the
way, that's why the fucoid the fucoid Z
is such an amazing product.
>> The fucoidon is one of the power
ingredients in algae.
Mhm. I
>> I love how the most humblest creatures,
the bacteria and the algae, are the most
impactful and arguably the most
important on the planet. Not us.
>> The al and the bacteria.
>> Yes, Victor.
>> I love Adrien Gold. I'm not No on
>> No, I know you love Adrien Gold. You've
you've you've
>> I've known her for many years.
>> Your love for her and her her late
husband as well.
>> Late husband as well. Absolutely. you
you've mentioned many times. Um
uh Victor, I appreciate your many
comments here. You remember Victor?
>> Victor Delage. How does he say his name?
>> Yeah.
>> Did I say it right? Delage.
>> Uh no, but that's okay.
>> What's What's he saying?
>> First names on television.
>> Okay. All right.
>> Uh okay. So now Andy's question. If
someone has had repeated
you you you go for this one.
>> If somebody has repeated what
>> systo
where where you looking at is in the
comments.
>> If someone Yeah. Uh it's on the screen.
If someone has
>> spell it for me. I don't see on my
screen.
>> Repeated systocop systop.
>> Spell it. Uh, C Y S T O S C O P I E S
C
systocopies.
>> Okay. So, what are they scoping for
>> over a few years? Can that cause urinary
symptoms like stinging, interrupted
flow, and inability to fully empty?
Meaning the screening has
>> Yes. Absolutely. Absolutely. First of
all, why would they have the cystoscop
systocoscopies
systoscope a cystoscope is the is the
device a cystoscopy
>> is the procedure.
>> Yeah. Um
>> so yes for a couple things absolutely
they could be related. The uh first of
all you have to ask why are they um like
getting cystoscopies right? Is that is
that is that is that as painful as I'm
imagining that they're sticking a a
>> I hope they numb it. I hope they numb
it. I don't know much about the
procedure.
>> I hope they numb it. A cystoscopy
um
first of all there's something wrong in
the urethra, you know, or the bladder or
something. A cyst is like in this term
in in this case, I think it refers to
the bladder. So, and so a cystoscopies
they're looking in the bladder. Um, and
but you got to go through the urethra if
you can imagine. And so I think they
numb it probably, but it might be sore
after they take it out. I guess I don't
know much about it. And but yes, it can.
Uh, anything you could do to help heal
epithelia and connective tissue.
Epithelia is the surface of the skin, ep
the connective tissues underneath.
Healthy bone and joint pack, vitamin C,
u Beyond Tangy Tangerine, lots of it.
You gota be a little careful. Might hurt
you to pee. So if you're drinking a lot
of water, I guess that might be a
problem. Um, but all the stuff that
heals. Hang on a second here. Hang on a
second here. Hey, I gotta call you back.
Okay. Okay. Um, sorry about that. And I
do have to go. It's already late. Wait.
So, I have some, believe it or not,
other calls to make here. Um, so, uh,
yes, a cystoscopy, a cystoscopies can
cause inflammation in the urethra.
Absolutely. Um, and I would go with the
healthy bone and joint pack. I would go
with all the um all the the beyond tangy
tangerine electrolytes, all the B
complex, but that's beyond tangy
tangerine general healing. Zinc, zinc's
really important for healing. Vitamin E
is important for healing.
Zinc is probably the most important
healing
next to vitamin C. Vitamin C is probably
the most important, but zinc is probably
the second most. You know about zinc
losenes?
>> Mhm.
>> So zinc losenes, if you suck on zinc,
they'll heal your heal your throat,
right? Mhm.
>> The zinc melts, it drips and it hits
your throat and it heals your sore
throat. A systocopy is a sore throat
except in another part of the body.
>> Same idea.
>> Mhm.
>> Right.
>> So So would you put
>> imagine having a sore throat in your you
know in your
>> Would you put a put a dropper of um
>> No, I wouldn't put anything in there.
No, I wouldn't put a dropper in there.
>> You wouldn't do that. Okay.
>> No. Would you do that? Would a dropper
where?
>> What are you talking? Were you where
you're thinking? Yes. Were you thinking?
>> Yes. That No, I would not do that.
>> You wouldn't do that.
Pharmacist Ben, before I let you go, the
most important question in the past 53
years.
>> Yes.
>> What did you think of the Knicks
victory?
>> You know, I have to say I heard about
it, but I don't follow basketball
really, but I know I don't really follow
basketball, but I do know for me in New
York that it was an amazing thing. You
know, I do know when I read it, well,
first of all, I didn't even know about
it until I read they were in the in the
final game. I was like, what is that? I
couldn't believe is that the first time
I was like, is that a you know, I didn't
know because I hadn't followed
basketball in years and um and then I
read it. It was said Nick Knicks are in
the finals and I was like, what? And
then they won it. Yeah, it was kind of
weird. I don't even know who's on the
Knicks.
>> I don't really follow basketball. I
remember Willis Reed. I remember Earl
the Pearl. I remember um Dave de Busher.
I remember there was another power
forward bill somebody he was a senator.
>> Yep. Bradley
>> Bill Bradley. Dollar Bill Bradley.
>> And um who am I missing here? Oh, of
course. Wall Frasier.
>> Wall Frasier. Clyde Frasier.
>> I remember that.
>> Former I just want to tell you about the
the point guard. This guy is this guy
named uh Jaylen Brunson. the son of a
guy who played with Jordan and was on
the Knicks last team that made the
>> What was his name? What was his name?
>> His name was Rick Brunson.
>> Huh. Interesting. In the 80s.
>> Uh 90s. 2000.
>> Are you too young for the 80s? The 80s
were like that was amazing time. Did you
watch
>> My favorite ball player of all time is
Moses Malone.
>> Oh, Moses Malone. Bird.
>> Larry Bird's name. Bird's name.
>> Larry Bird.
>> Everyone's got their favorites. Jordan
was great. There's a lot of great ones.
>> All right.
>> Oh, you got But just this real quick,
this this kid Rick Brunson
>> Yeah.
>> in uh they went his he is three guys on
the Knicks that he played with at um
not Providence at at wherever,
Villanova. They went to Villanova and
they won championships at Villanova. And
now these three kids are playing for the
Knicks
>> really
>> and they won the championship with the
Knicks. But this
>> NBA championship,
>> but this kid Rick Brunson
>> Yeah. Amazing.
>> I remember him. He he what he is, he
uses mental
strength. He's not the fastest. He's not
the tallest. He But he works the
hardest.
>> Uhhuh. practices the hardest over the
summer
>> and has will has the willpower.
>> Yeah.
>> Of a Ben Fuches. He
>> I don't know about I don't know about
that. But
>> I So is he big guy? Is he big?
>> 61.
>> 61. That's great. I love stories like
that. John Stockton. Those guys. The
small guys. Yeah. the small guys that
can that's that's amazing because I
don't know who if other people have not
anybody's you know I'm not sure
everybody's been to an NBA game
>> those guys are freaks of nature there is
no other way to describe them no other
way to describe a 6'11
300B
pure muscle being like they're from
another dimension or something and then
we got this little 61 white guy you know
She's like shooting three-pointers and
passing.
>> But the guy they were playing against is
74 from France.
>> Yeah. And not just 74, he's probably
ripped. Is he black guy?
>> Half and half. He's halfway.
>> Some of these guys because black guys
have more androgens. The more they are
like, holy moly. What dimension
these guys from?
>> Of all colors.
>> What's that?
>> I've seen rip people of all colors.
>> Yeah. Yeah. But not in the NBA. The
white guys are doughier in the NBA. Like
the white guys are
>> We're going to end there.
>> Okay. All right.
>> Thanks for another episode of
businesses. You're the man. Pharmacist
Ben. I really enjoy talking to you at
all times. We'll see you Friday.
>> I'll see you Friday.
>> Thank you, sir.
>> All right. Take care. Bye, everybody.
Bye.
Watch me.
A diagnosis of ALS or severe muscle
wasting is often treated as an
inescapable genetic sentence. The
prevailing medical view is that your
body has simply decided to fail and
there is no intervention capable of
stopping the decline. When we view these
conditions as a systemic metabolic
breakdown, the focus shifts from a
mysterious destiny to a mechanical
reality, we stop looking for curses and
start looking for failures in the body's
self-repair systems. Pharmacist Ben
describes human health as a constant
balancing act on a biological seessaw.
On one side is anabolism, building
tissue, on the other catabolism,
breaking it down. In extreme muscle
wasting, that seesaw violently snaps.
The body becomes trapped in runaway
catabolism. It's a terrifying reality.
Your body is actively consuming its
muscle tissue, literally eating itself
faster than it can patch the damage and
rebuild. You cannot out medicate this
state of decay. To actually halt the
decline, you have to answer the root
question. What triggered the body to
attack its own tissue in the first
place? There is a core principle in
holistic health where you see the
problem is almost never where the
problem begins. To understand dying
muscles in the limbs, we have to trace
the physiological forensics backward
straight to the digestive system. When
you consume highly inflammatory foods
like processed fats and refined sugars,
they damage the delicate lining of your
intestines. Over time, these irritants
punch microscopic holes in that barrier,
a condition known as leaky gut. Instead
of absorbing nutrients, your compromised
gut allows a flood of bacterial debris
and undigested food particles to leak
directly into your bloodstream. This
debris turns the blood thick and toxic,
a state pharmacist Ben calls dirty
blood. To protect your vital organs from
this contamination, your body shumps
this debris toward the periphery, the
connective tissues and limbs.
Simultaneously, the blood thickens in an
immune response to trap the toxins. This
sluggish, hypercoagulable blood can no
longer navigate the microscopic
capillaries that feed your cells,
leaving the muscles suffocating and
functionally starving. Bathed in this
acidic, oxygen depleted environment, the
muscle tissue reaches a breaking point.
individual cells begin to die and as Ben
describes it, they literally explode,
spewing their internal enzymes and acids
directly into the surrounding tissue.
This cell explosion creates a vicious
cycle. The debris from the ruptured
cells floods the kidneys, straining your
primary filters and triggering massive
inflammation that drives the body into
even more aggressive muscle catabolism.
You cannot rebuild a house in the middle
of a hurricane. Before any repair can
begin, you must execute an emergency
triage response and completely cut off
the stream of toxicity. The fastest way
to do that is a 24 to 48 hour water
fast. By stopping the intake of food
entirely, you stop the influx of toxins
and give your hyperactive immune system
and overworked digestive tract a
mandatory reset. When you resume eating,
the guesswork has to end. You must keep
a strict food diary to track how your
body responds to every meal, allowing
you to identify and permanently
eliminate the specific triggers causing
your inflammation. With the toxic influx
stopped, you have to clean up the
wreckage in the blood. This requires
taking systemic enzymes, specifically
ultimate enzymes on a completely empty
stomach. Because there is no food in the
stomach to digest, these enzymes pass
directly into the bloodstream. They act
like a rotorooer for the vascular
system, seeking out and dissolving the
inflammatory proteins and dead cellular
debris clogging the blood flow. By
sealing the gut, neutralizing the blood
debris, and aggressively flushing the
kidneys with water and plant derived
minerals, the emergency is contained.
The body is finally prepared for the
rebuilding phase. Now you transition to
the offensive strategy. To restore the
atrophied limbs, you have to move the
biological seesaw out of breakdown and
back into anabolism. Muscles are
composed almost entirely of protein.
Synthesizing new muscle fibers is
chemically impossible if your body lacks
the exact raw materials required to
build them. You must saturate your
system with branch chain amino acids and
whey protein. These are the building
blocks that trigger muscle repair and
growth without placing a heavy metabolic
burden on your digestive system.
Creatine is also a necessary addition
for any condition involving muscle
wasting. It provides the essential
energy to protect fragile recovering
muscle tissue while simultaneously
supporting neurological health. But
muscle fibers do not exist in a vacuum.
They require a physical structural
matrix, the body's internal scaffolding
to attach and anchor themselves to. The
healthy bone and joint pack, gluco gel
caps, and collagen peptides provide the
critical goo and fibers necessary to
rebuild the entire physical framework
that holds the muscles in place. A
rebuilt structure and new muscle fibers
provide the potential for movement, but
the nerves provide the command. Without
a healthy electrical signal, the muscles
remain dormant. To restore the grid, you
have to saturate the cells with all 90
essential nutrients, focusing
specifically on those that facilitate
electrical nerve conduction. This brings
us to thamine or vitamin B1. Historical
biochemical discoveries proved that
severe nerve pain and the wooden legs of
peripheral neuropathy were directly
reversed by reintroducing this vitamin
to the diet. Thamine restores the
electrical conduction required for
nerves to function. It allows signals
from the brain to travel without
interruption and successfully fire the
muscle fibers. This is the protocol's
goal. Clean blood, rebuilt structure,
and restored electrical signals working
together in perfect coordination. A
diagnosis of severe muscle wasting is
not a mandate for passive decline. By
controlling the gut, clearing the blood,
and feeding the growth pathways,
patients have the agency to redirect
their metabolism from active breakdown
towards structural renewal.
Ooh.
Hey. Hey.
Where are you?